Extra extra.
Come hear all about it.
Yeah.
Look at my hat you like it?
On you?
Yes.
I don't think I could pull it off.
It looked like a bubble head, but this, this
this old timey cap is back and it's not for everyone
but the Wall Street Journal reports
that the flat cap is having a renaissance.
And you know, if it's the hat of the newsies,
the old time golfer or sweet old grand poppy.
But now this hat is everywhere
on shows like Peaky Blinders and Lupin.
Idrissa Elba is rocking it,
Leona Caprio, Brad Pitt,
Ross Matthews, Drew Barrymore.
Basically every of the hottest
like eligible bachelors on the planet.
Yeah, well I'm taken, but the other ones yeah
they, they are.
But what do you think?
Do you think this is
a cute look that we can pull off?
This works with your outfit right now, Drew.
I feel very like, I love hats.
Yeah, I don't know that I have a face for hats.
I beg to differ.
Don't you say that about Ross.
(Ross chuckles)
I don't know.
This feels like I'm wearing someone else's hat.
Yours is at an angle.
Should, should I angle it?
Is that gonna help?
I like, I say go jonti.
You know what much better.
Honestly I think it is better.
It is.
Yeah, okay.
Well that's what I'm talking about.
When in doubt go jonti okay.
Next we're going from flat caps to face caps.
Vogue reports facial cupping is the latest skincare trend
that also relieves facial tension.
Gosh, I need some of that.
Literally this morning I woke up and I was like
grind harder woman.
I was like,
(straining voices)
Oh, oh.
Yeah, I know I've got like TMJ.
So I'm interested in this.
I think I have a lot of fish at Jen.
And here to talk with us about it
and walk us through it
is friend of the show writer, beauty expert.
Mianne Chan.
(audience clapping)
Hi.
Nice to see you again.
Well, Mianne I have implicit trust with you.
You are one of my favorite beauty gurus,
and I know that you're just starting to explore
facial cupping for yourself.
And I was wondering if you can give us like
a primer, a tip,
what's the benefit?
Take us through it Mien.
Facial cupping has been around for a very long time
but I think it's kind of picking up steam right now.
Everyone's at home.
It's essentially a very deep,
more facial massage it uses suction with your blue cup.
And it basically pulls the facial muscles
to promote circulation.
It can contour, it deep puffs that helps to plump,
it can brighten.
And honestly, it just feels really, really, really good.
Okay I didn't know it would look like that.
It's I wanna try this.
Oh, Oh
Oh wow.
Oh
Okay first of all Mianne,
do I need like a product
or like
an oil?
Do I need anything with it?
Yeah, so the first thing definitely most important
is to get an oil or serum.
I'm gonna have a little bit of oil here
and apply it to your face
because you really want to promote the movement of the cups.
You never want the cups to be stationary on your face.
That's how you end up with bruising.
You want them to always be gliding
on your face.
Now you tell me thanks.
Mianne-
I like that .
And I was like-
I know
But you're, you're fine.
Like the facial cups are very, very gentle.
They kind of feel like little fairy kisses.
And what you wanna do,
is I really like to focus on my jaw.
You said you have TMJ I do too.
And it's really helpful for
relieving tension, massaging that area.
What I like to do is bring it down the jawline afterward
just to help drain that excess fluid,
drain that limp.
I like to contour the cheek bone with it as well
bring it up.
Oh, you had me-
Very satisfying.
at like fade and away.
She has the best cheekbones in the world.
The best.
Yeah, and there are different sizes here too.
So there's a bigger size which is great for the jaw
great for the cheekbone.
And there's a little one that's great
for the delicate under eye area.
Really great for plumping your lips.
Actually, if you want a-
Fuller.
very thick little, instant little lip plump,
you can kind of use the suction.
Oh, hi, hi.
(Drew laughs)
I've done it, and just like that.
(Ross and audience laugh)
But definitely make sure you're continuing to move
and be very gentle on your skin.
You don't wanna pull too much.
You don't wanna do anything that could be harmful.
I like one, I literally went to like under eye and like
it was like, I took my eye splash and was like, okay.
(Ross and audience laugh)
Do this.
This is very satisfying.
Mianne I actually wanted to meet your story
with facial acupuncture.
Do you know anything about that treatment?
Yeah, so I've actually had it done before.
I think the first things first is
always go to a licensed professional
when you're gonna get facial acupuncture.
You don't wanna be messing around with needles
that are in your home,
but it is a really, really amazing procedure
Can help lift.
When I actually did it, my acupuncturist did on half my face
and I didn't do the other half.
So I could really see the lifting effect that it can have.
Really it was instantaneous?
Did you see results?
Yeah, in the first time
in the first time you get a little bit of results
but you really should be going like, you know
eight consecutive times
to get a really really dramatic effect.
But it's really nice for relieving tension
and just improving circulation overall
with blood and limp in your system.
Now, Mianne I also
saw this
and I wanted to bring this to you.
It's called Double Moss and it doubles
as a ring and a palette
for your makeup.
And since you paint
like these intricate little beautiful artistic moments
on your face, how do you feel about this?
Yeah, so that is actually
on my wishlist right now.
I love it because it's a beautiful ring
but it's also so practical.
So a lot of makeup artists will use the back of their hand.
They'll use pallets like this to mix.
I am not, I don't do make up on other people.
I usually do it on myself
but even I think that that would be really useful
for me just to mix different colors
and then you can just really easily wipe it off after.
And honestly it looks like a normal ring.
So it's kinda, it's kind nice to have on you.
And when you make those beautiful little hearts
and puffy clouds
and like the little baby details that you do.
I just pictured this with you.
Sorry Ross you go.
No, I just never would have thought to use this.
I'm gonna use this for when I make a cheese plate.
Cause this is like the serving size
I should be having right?
Just there's like-
You can put jam on it.
Yes please.
If you, you said this is on your wishlist.
It is, I really
it's like been on my saved for a while.
It's beautiful.
Well guess what, I'm gonna send you this one, right?
Is that okay?
Yes!
Absolutely.
I was gonna give her mine too.
Guess what you just got two.
(excited shouts)
(upbeat music)